MARC-ANDRE FLEURY MOVING ON TO
CHICAGO ANDND IT
IS P ON THE
BACK END MARTINEZ.
ZADINA, DOWN TIME FOR A
19-YEAR-OLD AND, BOOM, A COUPLEK
FOR LEDDY, AT
NUMBER MOVED THERE BY ROY AND BK
INTOTE
BOUNCE THERE FOR VEGAS.
KEN: BERTUZZI HERE, GOAL.
THAT WAS FRONTED AND NOW SOM ASS
WITH SEVEN PICKS IN THE FIRST
FOUR R
THERE FROM THEVE A TON OF ENERG.
KEN: THREE ASSISTS, BACK TO THE
BERTUZZI, RAYMOND, KNOCKED DOWN
THAT TIME BY McNABB AS HOME FORT
ONE, IT
[ LAUGHTER ]
KEN: NICOLAS ROY.
MICKEY: THEY'VE FOUND THEMSELVES
AA
MICKEY: A LOOSE PUCK THERE
THAT DETROIT COULD NOT GET TO, T
IT IN,
AND TIPPED IN FRONT, SUTER, ONCE
AGAIN! BLOCK IT.
AND THE VEGAS GOLDEN KNIGHTS ON
NOW BEHIND THEE BUT GOOD, BENCH
FOR THE EXTRA SKATER AND
[ APPLAUSE ]
[ CHEERING AND APPLAUSE ]